welcome all millions of new subscribers
that don't want t-series to win
to my closet review
closet review what's inside felix's
closet
pewdiepie he uploads gaming videos right
just kidding
closet review so this is uh something
that has been
requested by maybe two or three people i
did a closet
video a few years back and here we are
finally the thing that everyone has been
waiting for
closet tour part 2. can we get some
closet tour part 2 hype in the chat guys
are you zooming in on my face oh yeah
okay first off as you notice new closet
smash like if you think it's a cooler
closet second of all
i've been kind of scared to make this
video because uh i said a lot of stuff
that i regret in that video a lot of
preachy
preachy stuff about no i i wouldn't
spend money on like this that's so dumb
and here i am
i spend money on everything i'm sorry
first of all this is a
no judgment zone okay so no one can
judge me
i'm looking at you you cannot judge me
okay i said i stopped drinking and i
don't spend money on whiskey anymore
what am i gonna spend youtube money on
wow what a diverse and nice
closet is your immediate thought isn't
it wow he sure likes black disney
closet review where do i begin that one
this one this is the latest one i bought
it's uh
this is a problem when you have black
clothings and pugs
i still wear it for some reason it's
from june g
i think it's japanese i don't know
you'll probably notice that
most of my items are very oversized i
really like this one
it's a really cool fit look guys it's
fake it's not
actually layered that's fashion do you
see this i'm wearing
that's fashion what purpose does it have
absolutely nothing
that's fashion smash like i really like
uh
oversized clothing here's another
oversized
this is from garcia gosh is one of my
favorite brands you probably
for those who you know the brand it's a
really cool russian designer
he really brings back the the feeling of
being homeless
in russia but paying hundreds of dollars
to have the look
is that a good explanation i really love
this one
it's such a good fit it has got these
baggy arms as well
i like hoodies okay i kind of have a
problem with hoodies one of my
more recent favorite brands is a
japanese brand
might say got me this for a video
because you were gonna dress me right
and you got this on sale please don't
judge me how much money i spend on club
okay
i'm not trying to flex this is just i
have a problem this is sad
is what i'm saying wait i love ken
haven't i don't know how to pronounce a
every time i say a brand wrong they're
like
it's kevont it's french no it's japanese
it's a super cool brand uh if you guys
want to get
some pieces follow them on twitter
because that's how you get the hot stuff
this is camped as well this is so cringy
i freaking love it and they have this
one as well
i love this shirt a lot of fashion now
is neon this type of green
kind of like i don't know how to just
explain it computer is she
that's what i try to do with pew news
the merch but
i don't think anyone cares seriously
they have the coolest designs i just see
their
i see everything from them and i'm like
i want it i want it all
i feel like my uh opinion about clothing
has changed a lot with
it's nice to own some nicer things is
what i'm saying
treat yourself i guess before i would
buy
maya please i'm talking about fashiony
before i would buy maybe
one cheap item and i would wear it once
and then it's like i don't really care
about even making it nice but you buy
nicer pieces of clothing even though
it's filled with hair you kind of want
to take care of it more
that's how i feel like uh my mom bought
me this
i guess vests were cool for a while but
it didn't last long
maybe they'll come back i don't think
anyone wears best
it was one of those fads that if you
fell for it
you're kind of a loser but thanks mom
anyway i really like it anyway i don't
care
all right that's a nice vest man did
your mom buy it
yeah she did shut up i and she's lovely
i bet you wish your mom bought you
clothes another brand i really like
is adder heather
this is a korean brand i think i'm not
sure they're
doing a collection that's it's kind of
old computer
i guess like a lot of fashion now is
retro subtle retro
kind of like a throwback to the 90s if
you check out this brand
it's very me me it's kind of like
everyone's wearing these silly
sunglasses it doesn't take itself kind
of seriously but
still is edgy at the same time in a
weird way
you like this one it's got a good fit to
it too and if you want a
unique piece you kind of have to pay a
bit more
which is a bit i it's annoying i wish i
had cheaper brands to actually recommend
one thing that i really like to do is
layer sweaters with a polo shirt or
something like that
this also had her it's got a weird like
youtube logo on it it's kind of strange
but it looks cool when you layer it
really i like doing that a lot
i had one of the in my lasagna
video i had a layered polo shirt
underneath and uh
i love that polo shirt so much i thought
it looked so cool to layer it and i was
like oh this is so dope
i found a thing that is like cool and
not a lot of people have it
and this is mine and i watched it
and it shrank and it costs five hundred
dollars
another great brand that i like is daily
paper
um i think they're based in amsterdam uh
but they focus on kind of african
culture
africa but they're really cool i like
this because it's finally not a black
sweater in my collection
i'll take it it looks good they also
have really neat
looking pants if you guys are looking
for some pants i recommend
daily paper great fabric great fit all
the pants they have are really good
they're kind of cool too right speaking
of pants
these are also pretty cool there's a
japanese brand called
mahara maharishi
which is supposed to be military design
they did a collection
with the censorship in the media and i
thought that was interesting
they got like these little thingy tie
around your legs as well
it's kind of cute any small stuff like
that you know you want to stand out a
bit you're like yeah i'll tie
i'll tie a little thing there or if
you're feeling extra fancy
you let them loose you let them red
but that's if you're an absolute mad
light also
y3 very cool belt it stands out i think
it's small
details and small accessories that
really makes your outfit
look so much more it's i'm stating the
obvious here but
it's just so it's just one of those
things that i didn't use to care about
but i really enjoy trying out different
things
i guess because a lot of people have
been asking about this sweater it's
really cool
a4 it's a i know it's a collaboration
yeah
it's kaplan a4 modded in japan really my
addiction with fashion started in japan
because everyone was if you ever been to
tokyo everyone just dressed
so freely people just wear whatever they
want and
they are not being judged i really love
that i really miss that just going
outside and
wearing whatever you feel like and just
embracing that it's really fun
so last video i mentioned my favorite
sweater with this one
because it's very oversized but if you
think this is oversized
you ain't saying nothing yet because
everything is just getting
super sized you can't even tell what's a
joke sometimes anymore this is bed
months it's no big deal
it's whatever uh it's inside out it's
pretty cool
i really like it they always do such
crazy things
an inside out sweater what are they
gonna do next
a shirt on top of a shirt that's crazy
clothes are just getting bigger and
bigger maybe i'm just shrinking
i love this thing it's a bag from alex
alex is one of my favorite brands
i know it's not called alex anymore but
i can't bother
i always wear this and people are like
what is that and i'm like it's fashion
fit
what the where else am i gonna keep
my keys
how fast can you grab your keys
[Music]
i thought you always catch things
what are you doing
putting it look at that mindset has a
talent so black pants black hoodies
felix wow this is a really interesting
versatile closet i really enjoy it
alright well how about
black caps everybody you want some black
caps
oh yeah this is i love this
listen you will never understand their
power
unless you have this the power of
wearing
a saturday hat on a saturday here's one
of those things you buy online and
you're like why did i buy that
cool how do i wear this someone tell me
i love weed types but what the
is this we got the sukabia white donald
time to respect women
[Music]
the most important of all the gucci face
mask
if you don't have one of these in your
closet then what are
you doing you're not fashion unless you
own one of these
let's move on to uh accessories
i also have these sunglasses i wore
these for my mcdonald's
or white dolls i mean sorry don't sue me
please that was a joke
a lot of people have been asking about
the sunglasses i had in
lasagna uh they're swedish they're
called command i think
i'll link them if you guys are
interested there's this instagram
blog that every time i wear a new outfit
they
figure out where i bought the clothes
from and i'm always so amazed that they
actually found it but one of the few
things they haven't found out is the
glasses so there you go
no one cares moving on what else we got
what the hell are you doing we also have
the tsuki i love this one
so cool do you guys like it tsuki
selling out
fast mcdonald's i love this one
i had a lot of fun making this i finally
made it the
belt fit the 200 i bought this belt for
200 pounds
and i could not fit it through any pants
but i managed
okay you just need a lot of time and a
lot of patience
and you can make it happen but they're
staying on these pants i'm never taking
them off
that's right i have about 50 pairs of
black pants what are you gonna do judge
me
judge freeze zone you can't do that here
mindset posted
wearing one of these and they liked it
but i wear them all the time and they
never like it
what the frick it's a cool bride i like
herring preston i like oversized hoodies
is anyone surprised
what else do we got one thing that i
said in
my closet video that everyone's been
giving me which is the fact that i i
said like oh yeah
i like to have like a lot of watches
because then a lot of cheap ones because
then i can just like keep changing them
because i always get bored
that's what i said i never wear these
anymore the thing is
i bought this uh this watch it's not
like crazy expensive but it's still an
expensive watch
and i bought it because uh when i
proposed to marzia
you got a ring and i'm like what what do
i get and everyone's always saying oh if
you're gonna buy a watch you should buy
it for an occasion and i thought okay
what better occasion to buy a watch than
than our engagement so that's why i got
this rolex i really
love it it really changed my whole
opinion on watches because i i usually
didn't used to get it i was like why
would you spend so much money on a watch
that's just stupid
uh preachy moment incoming the reason i
like it so much is because
i think with fashion and clothes and
accessories and all this stuff in
general
it's always so fast pretty much don't
wear most of the stuff that i had from a
year ago and
i i love the fact that i have one item
that i'm always gonna have
because it's associated with some some a
memory so this watch will always have a
meaning to me and
that's why i really like it obviously it
doesn't have to be expensive to do that
but also the fact that
it will last you a lifetime which makes
a difference please don't hate me okay i
changed my mind
i also have this this is my wallet it's
kind of cool
it's a good way to make sure that you
die in case just
spice up your life a little bit you know
why not make sure that you could
possibly
get stuck into something seems like a
great idea right
hey accessorize guys you have to learn
to accessorize
shoe time so in my video with dave and
uh and joel they made fun of me for
having big shoes
you should see the shoes felix squares
every day they're like this big
this they're not they're not but they're
not
that big this is a swedish brand called
80s
i love these shoes i wanted to buy shoes
with big souls because i
i know what's going to be hit i know
what's going to be trendy and i was like
big shoes it's popping i want to find a
pair but i could not find a one i liked
80s dropped these and i was just like
bam i'm buying these
epic style i realize it's kind of
pathetic i'm just trying to
hide the fact that i'm a manly but they
look so good
what are those guys oh you like these
pants that i'm wearing
that's right buy cargo pants right now
super hit
super lit what are you doing if you're
not wearing pants that it doesn't at
least have four pockets
then what's the point huh
you can't do this these are alex pants
it's no big deal i don't really look at
brands i'm not
really brand conscious i just buy what i
like these aren't alex pants by the way
and finally this is my jacket i got it
in japan
they have yen in japan and i i didn't
really figure i didn't realize how much
it cost
i remember they told me the price and i
was just like oh sure
i'll buy it but i'm actually really glad
i got it i actually love it
it's a really cool jacket it's kind of
another meme like it's so oversized
if you wear this you just you would just
disappear i think it's cool okay i don't
care
judgment-free so a while back when uh
the triple s valencia i guess were
super popular i wanted to buy them but i
also
thought i just couldn't get myself to do
it because i was like no
everyone has a triple-a so now i want to
be different so i bought these
instead which i never wear
because why did i buy expensive white
shoes what the hell was i thinking
you walk on these all the time anytime
anytime
anytime i wear these and i'm out with
marzia i just have to keep like
a distant from her to make sure
that no one steps on these and if we're
at a restaurant with other people and
someone accidentally touch your shoe
which happens you know
and they go oh i'm sorry and i go ah
that's fine
but inside i'm like you
what are you these are
young i do end up not wearing them great
purchase
great story i know hasn't this been a
great time
i had fun look how wide these shoes are
though honestly like
i did a good job that was fashion closet
tour
welcome to my closet see you next year
bye bye
smash like and subscribe so i can beat t
series this is my secret plan b that
i've been talking about
[Music]
breakfast
[Applause]